but hold on if this is going to work we
got to make sure Biden doesn't have the
same problem yeah he's got to be clean
so then he orders the search of Biden's
property not because he's targeting
Biden because he's helping Biden I see
so trying to make Trump look worse and
if Biden gets out of office and then
they did the raids it would annihilate
the Biden name it would make him they'd
be like look you've got all the same
things you hypocrite so they're just
getting out of the way is that what
you're saying they when they re when
they raided his house the first time no
one knew this was in November they
covered it up they they they no one knew
it happened okay so I'm thinking you
know we were talking about this last
week like why would why would they go
after buying is the Deep State trying to
remove him like ending his 20 24 chances
maybe it could be both it could be this
they know Joe Biden can't run in 2024
he's not going to win yeah they also
don't want Trump to run and he will win
what do you do oh oh geez oh Biden you
broke the record keeping you can't run
for president now oh man that means
Trump can't run either oh